SPEAKER: The best way to
maximize cost optimization
for Google Kubernetes Engine
is to make sure your app
and GKE are configured
for each other.
Today, we'll talk about
some tips and best practices
for configuring GKE
to work with your app,
and we'll wrap up our
cost optimization journey.
Let's go beyond your GKE bill.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The last video went over some
tips for configuring your app.
And the videos
before that covered
a lot of best practices.
If you haven't seen
the previous videos,
make sure to watch them
before you watch this one.
I'll start with some suggestions
for batch and serving
workloads.
Then, we'll do some
networking, and finally,
wrap up the whole video series
and talk about what's next.
As always, knowledge
about your application
can help you focus on which
cost-optimization techniques
will give you the most impact.
We can simplify
most applications
by grouping them
into two groups--
batch and serving.
Batch applications
have work to do,
but tend to be less
concerned about startup time
and usually aren't
time-sensitive overall.
Apps like monthly data
calculations or low priority
data transformation are
great examples of batch jobs.
As these jobs need
to be scheduled,
the cluster autoscaler
can spin up new nodes,
and then remove them
when the job is done.
Even better, node
autoprovisioning
works best with batch
workloads since it
can figure out
optimal resources,
and then create a new node
pool, and doesn't need to worry
as much about spikes in demand.
Here's some other tips for
working with batch workloads.
The cluster autoscaler
can delete empty nodes
faster when it doesn't
need to also restart
the pods on those nodes.
Splitting up your applications
into dedicated node pools,
using labels and selectors
or taints and tolerations,
can help the cluster
autoscaler scale quicker
and avoid wasted resources.
There's even an
optimize-utilization profile
for the cluster autoscaler
that focuses more
on maximizing utilization
rather than keeping
spare resources at the ready.
It scales down a lot quicker,
which can help aggressively
minimize extra resources.
Also, you can separate
different applications
with node auto-provisioning,
along with using
taints and tolerations.
Node pools will then be better
sized for each application,
once again, optimizing
your resource usage.
And don't forget that
preemptible VMs are
much cheaper to use, but only
if your apps are fault-tolerant
and much less time-sensitive.
Opposite of batch
applications are
serving apps, which need
the ability to scale rapidly
in response to
spikes in demand--
for example, a retail website
on major shopping holidays.
In order to handle the
sudden increases in demand,
it's good for serving
workloads to be
lean and optimized to
work best with GKE.
The quicker that
pods can start up,
the more efficient autoscalers
are at responding to demand.
If you have a serving app
that requires resources
with a long provisioning
time, like, GPUs,
it makes sense to
overprovision and have
resources at the ready
before the demand spikes.
Plus, you can use pause pods
to help you scale ahead.
We went over some
ways to overprovision
and to keep your apps lean
in the previous videos.
Optimizing both of
those will give you
the most cost-efficient way
to handle high-demand spikes.
Here's another best
practice for GKE.
Make sure to use
NodeLocal DNSCaching.
If you're running a
version with kube-dns,
apps that make a
lot of DNS lookups
will put extra pressure on it.
While the kube-dns
autoscaler will
create more kube-dns
replicas, it
takes time to add those replicas
and increases resource usage.
Instead of just increasing
the kube-dns replicas
in your configuration, add
the NodeLocal DNSCache add-on.
Each node will then
store a DNS cache,
which helps kube-dns
require less resources
and saves overall
time for lookups.
On top of that, round-trip
request time is usually better
when it's low.
One tip for lowering this is
to use container-native load
balancing.
Rather than sending requests to
instance groups and then pods,
container-native load balancing
allows requests to go directly
to the pod by creating what's
called a Network Endpoint
Group.
When these are
configured, GKE Ingress
will handle the
creation of the L7 load
balancer, along with
forwarding rules, health
checks, firewalls, and more.
One quick tip for you-- if
you do container-native load
balancing, you'll want to start
failing your readiness probe
as soon as you receive
a SIGTERM, which
we talked a little bit
about in the last video.
That way the load
balancers will know
to stop forwarding new
requests to your app.
Not only does container-native
load balancing
provide improved load balancing
and more efficient autoscaling,
it can also enable you
to use other tools, like,
Traffic Director, and other
Google Cloud services.
All right, I know this was a
ton of information to absorb.
You can always
reference these videos
and the full best
practices guide, which
will be kept up to date as
new versions and tips are
available.
Plus, those tips lead
right to the documentation
for steps on how
to implement them.
Let's do a quick
summary and checklist.
Start with the culture and
move the cost discussion
to the left.
Help teams understand how
their work affects cost,
even if you've built an
abstraction layer between teams
and their clusters.
Try creating programs,
like, online classes
to help raise
familiarity and create
cost-optimization awareness.
Use monitoring to
better understand
how applications use
resources, and then
implement quotas,
requests, and limits,
that make sense for your
apps, while also minimizing
any wasted costs.
From machine families
to preemptibles,
you can optimize
your infrastructure
to improve performance
and save money.
Don't forget about committed
use discounts, too.
The cloud's dynamic
resources help
make autoscaling an
efficient strategy.
But configuring it correctly
for your applications
is vital to handling
spikes in demand,
while also balancing
performance with cost.
Make sure that you spend time
to increase your application's
compatibility with
Kubernetes and configuring
GKE for your application
for the best results.
Cost optimization is all about
increasing the business value
for what you get out of what
you're spending on the cloud.
Saving costs can
be a part of that,
but these tips are
more about getting
the most return out of costs
and optimizing your usage.
We've covered a
wide range of things
to consider when building,
scaling, and deploying on GKE.
Make sure to check out
the full best practices
guide for more details.
And thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]